[Musique]
il ya une embardée en numéro 10 vous
avez voté est ce que vous vous rappelez
de la chanson d'amour de jean michel mr
agir a dit ban jour où elle avait un
petit problème de gastro et c'est en
numéro 10 regardez et vous nous direz
vraiment si vous étiez vraiment amoureux
dit khalid et si à quel moment vous avez
perdu espoir d'accord parce que ce avec
elle beaucoup disent ils dans cette
émission mais là je veux que vous me
disiez la vérité elle a dû faire le taux
des trois lettres du quartier ont pu la
retrouver
des rouleaux de papier donné par le dit
elle reste marraine même assis sur son
trône elle fait plus de bruit qu'une
fois par d'autres au bord elle peut pas
dormir
ne pas dormir
[Applaudissements]
elle a dû faire
un tout autre des chiottes
pour être absente aujourd'hui elle a dû
faire d'autres les chiottes
de paris elle prend lieu aussi
[Applaudissements]
d'aller voir le classement c'est
incroyable numéro un eh ben je voudrais
dans un instant depuis l'homme disent
c'est ça jean michel vous étiez petit
croche -1 tick rush barbier auquel elle
elle cumule tout ce qu'on a envie de
nous voir chez une femme et les jeunes
agnel intelligente et drôle elle est
douce et en mettant sensuelle mais la
valeur n'est pas libre ça c'est son plus
gros défaut mais autrement
j'ai mis d'abandonner quand même ce que
j'aime pas briser des couples mais bon
j'ai tenté une petite fille joy safa
sais pas si vous connaissez vous n'avez
pas briser les couples bernard montiel
voit ce qu avait déjà mis un crush pour
une allée toute la vérité pour quelqu'un
dans l'émission bat kelly amoureux
d'amélie moi j'aime beaucoup qu'il met
que vous voulez donc vous pourriez faire
une histoire et kelly non je la trouve
château magnifique je trouve qu'elle est
très agréable c'est un bunker en plus
elle est belle mais alors qu'est-ce qui
vous soulage la différence d'âge
bah quand même je pourrais être son
grand-père c'est vrai mais je vous dirai
ça veut rien dire
c'est van der garde et vincent cassel
qui est très beau gosse avec avec une
jeune fille dans une position combien
d'écart 30 ans je préfère autant dans
les gares auriez donc ça veut rien dire
c'est faire évacuer de quoi et alors
quoi vous pourriez patrick bernard
montiel
jamais de la vie c'est comme mon papa
c'est une question d'actu voie est
fermée yeux tu penses à la france et tu
sais faire la cuisine moi ou pas non
voilà
[Applaudissements]
retournez voir des chiens nous met dans
vidéo gag numéro 9
numéro 9 en numéro 9 vous avez classé
dans les images les plus drôles de
l'histoire des pmp maxime guinea yogini
qui lors d'un prime time est partie du
plateau pour rencontrer l'amour et
l'amour c'est encore kelly voilà devait
et tout le monde est sur le bail de
billets j'avais demandé à la jeune fille
est ce que vous voulez qu'ils viennent
nous rejoindre
jade elle n'attend que ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bac 5 la déco pas applaudir à les
masquer la révolte et les verts ont donc
la voie je préférais le l'ottawa j'ai
pas tout intérêt à largement ça fait
plus jeunes dans des faits doit en fait
voir mais on peut leur nom passe à un
risque ma tête le mélange masse est si
vous voulez une question qui nous
peinons à ces horribles
la photo qui prennent aussi sur les
boissons chinois jeu de bénéficier le
client c'est incroyable en vrais
panneaux alors numéro 8
vous avez trouvé l'amour depuis avec lui
si ça se passe bien toujours ah ben non
merci merdier vote le truc a adressé un
jeu lancé l'histoire là non je préfère
pu reparler merci votre bien votre
action vous allez trouver quelqu'un vous
êtes magnifiques ces gens que vous dire
c'est qu'elle ne méritait pas même si on
aime bien moi je vous les remettez vous
sur kelly je pense que c'est la
meilleure chose à faire mais la paix n'a
pas l'air très déçu vous inquiétez pas
moi je pense que l'analyse mur il s'agit
de pierre françois martin laval pet qui
a fait une entrée fracassante plateau nu
qui juste après s'est fracassée vous
avez classé numéro 8 cette image
regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis dégoûté
beyrouth les gens d
j'ai toujours la honte devant ma famille
[Applaudissements]
à
alex persique de prendre
quelle recette celle de l'aigle
avec cet animateur à la consolidation
j'aime si les eagles à grande anse à ce
qu'on embrasse port quelle rigolade je
me rappelle est le mec qui veut pas
lâcher volume est aussi des caisses que
je suis lourd sans rigoler c'est pas
possible s'est classé numéro 8 ans
numéro 7
isabelle vous avez été classé numéro 7
par les téléspectateurs
à votre avis avec quoi c'est fini dans
lequel est très grand moment
nick et la finlande traîne dans la
gueule de tagab vous montrez je vais
faire une de leurs amies je vais vous
montrer l'attachement que j'ai beau mais
je vous laisse vous êtes là vous me
faites le pire truc qui me met de l'eau
sur la tête toi tu fais exprès comme une
match plein gré mine à la gueule toi
le ta gueule ta gueule toi la régate est
vrai les patients disent franchement non
mais vraiment c'est pour moi mon passage
préféré c'est le traîneau ou vous ça me
vous m'avez déhancher les bras pendant
qu'un jour je serais même si moi classé
vert aussi c'est moi qui pète un câble
alors je me rappelle plus du tout cette
image après que deux chroniqueurs
christophe carrière et nadège beausson
diagne se sont embrassés je me rappelle
plus du tout non je n'ai même pas que
c'était embrasser ses de la regarder
[Musique]
toi
[Applaudissements]
sa mère j'avais aimé on me rappelle ma
part ce qu'il dit les la pécho à
l'époque carrière il a été surtout les
barrières et la pêche aux personnes mais
elle est très jolie d'ailleurs elle a
d'ailleurs bon nombre à sport ivoire et
ses tenues mais alors pourquoi ça me met
dans un drôle mais moi je pense moi vois
les séries moi quand je vois de l'amour
et bien sûr
désolé j'ai joué devant maxime et payer
ensemble
eh ben je ferais pareil vous prendre un
poisson pour vous le far away plus soul
à la bagarre mais dès 10h pour un pool
tontine foule allait en numéro cinq
mondial eric il retrouve son amour
d'enfance
on avait dit à valérie les numéros 5 e
rang dans le top 5 vous avez choisi
c'est en numéro 5 c'est une d un des
plus gros joueurs que j'ai eu dans cette
émission
quand on lui a dit on a ramené ton ex
etc en fait pas du tout elle ne
connaissait pas le gars est le gars
était persuadé qu'il avait pécho valérie
bd oui monsieur quand vous appelez
philippe aime et c'est un mytho les mecs
sains
[Applaudissements]
la cour de récréation certainement 6e ou
en cm2 à pauline kergomard aquarelles
mais jamais été à l'école à sarcelles
[Applaudissements]
valérie vous avez été à l'école avec ce
monsieur c'est sûr mais c'est cyril je
te jure j'ai jamais été à l'école à
sarcelles bon d'accord en prime et
enchaînait tu désolé monsieur de très
sympa philippe a fini pas ce qui s'est
passé entre les peuples
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
le live jamais c'est incroyable histoire
même après à la fin de la séquence il
continue à me dire non mais vous êtes
sûr mais franchement vous allez monsieur
je suis désolé parce que moi j'ai alors
moi je vous rappelle je le rencontrais
dans un resto resto je me rappelle dans
une pizzeria voilà le choix du legs
valérie benaïm alors déjà je me suis
alors qu'il est très sympathique
non mais vraiment et après il dit sur
nous on a échangé il était très
sympathique et finalement ils benhaim en
fait pas du tout mais pas du tout je
voulais juste passer à la télé valérie
bénard ou en tout cas c'est pas les
rubena quelque chose balade on numéro 4
c'est l'arrivée de franck gastambide et
malik bentalha oui lors du prince voilà
où tout le monde et c'était incroyable
franchement c'est incroyable tout le
monde est tombé et je vous le redis
quand on asperge le plateau de mousse ne
courez pas surtout ne bougez pas voilà
rester en isabelle d'accord
[Musique]
regardez ce qui arrive à gâteau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à temps
[Applaudissements]
thierry guetta et je suis un gros bisou
à celui qui vous le savez qui est mon
frère voilà manic qui est en train de
nous regarder
certainement qu'ils étaient un petit peu
malade ces derniers jours voilà je fais
un gros bisou à malicki on pense fort à
lui allé au hand ball top 3 en numéro 3
c'est jean michel maire qui fait de la
corde à sauter on se rappelle tous les
je me rappelle ce moment où jean michel
maire m'avait dit quoi pour rappel avant
ce timing et je savais pas du tout que
ça allait se passer comme ça qu'est ce
qui s'est passé vous aviez posé une
question m'aviez dit quoi la vie des
stars le savent que ça ne risque rien
moi ça m'a demandé ça y est je risque
pas de but they large
[Rires]
[Musique]
allez c'est pas nous
[Applaudissements]
mais je voudrais qu'on vienne sur un
truc
regardez bien les gars de la technique
ils viennent de voir le skate de jean
michel maire ils veulent plus parler
regardez regardez regardez regardez
quand il sans regarder tous vos sous
pour regarder regardez bien la tête et
regarder de dégâts jusqu'au match du
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
genre c'est bon très peu pour moi quoi
le numéro 2 c'était mathieu delormeau
sous hypnose
quand je crois pour johnny hallyday
c'était un très très grand nombre aussi
vous l'avait placé numéro deux gardes
[Musique]
maire le chroniqueur son épouse il est
persuadé d'être géniale idée alors ça va
johnny est ce que vous êtes content de
votre nouvel album johnny écoute chez le
50e que j'ai fait et pour moi c'est
certainement une a les plus beaux albums
diony déjà ce que vous pouvez nous
chanter quelque chose oui comment donné
l'envi sauvé la vie quant à lui mme ma
vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bouzou le mec qui est persuadé il était
persuadé d'être vraiment johnny hallyday
quand vous le voyez comme ça non mais
franchement ça me met presque les larmes
aux yeux parce que j'avais vu cette
émission et que j'aime je l'avais
trouvée extraordinaire et là j'étais
déjà amoureuse de lui moi ça fait
c'étaient des années un chargeur mais là
il m'avait vraiment impressionné et il
est vraiment génial par un prénom mais
il la bonne solution
[Rires]
le top 1 le numéro un à la séquence que
vous avez trouvé la plus dark a alors
c'est une séquence qui s'est passé sur
france 4
c'était avec gégé de koh lanta à la
téléphone avec denis brogniart les
moines est avec moi et m'a chez bret
alors vous l'avez classe et c'est vous
qui a été grassement vous avez classé
number one
regardez gg oui vous vous voulez venir
ne touche pas mon pass vous me
connaissez oui
[Musique]
ce dernier a pas d'éducation est ce que
vous allez venir dans touche pas à mon
prince la semaine prochaine je lui
posais gg tu m'entends c'est denis ja ja
cyril hanouna qui voudrait savoir si tu
vas venir la semaine prochaine dans son
émission touche pas à mon poste
[Rires]
est ce que tu veux venir dans l'émission
la semaine prochaine geo vous embrasse
très fort en tout cas l on est due à
venir
[Applaudissements]
màj bravo denis brogniart contador est
un super mec denis et qui joue le jeu à
fond et j'ai géré gars qui on a appris à
nager dans cette émission j'ai un petit
bonus en plus ce qui pour moi c'est le
number one way
pour moi c'était avec camille sur
l'enfant de stars de zilina voilà pour
moi c'est mon kiff
voilà vous le met à nu ces c'était un
grand moment
ils avaient leur ai fait une danse
endiablée agile et apparemment ils ont
commis l'irréparable on a retrouvé la
photo de leur fille on l'a regardé
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
mais remplacé malouda photo montage
cette personne vie merci à mathieu
madénian on a vu la personne t bones qui
qui fait voilà donc on angoisse très
fort et s'ils aiment venir un jour de l
attrait bienvenus